Actually, I didn't try to solve the development problem that we had.
Brand new hardware, brand new software, you're testing the stuff out,...
...it would hang up all the time.
So the only solution you have is to turn the power off, wait a few seconds,...
...turn the power back on, and wait for it to go through the power-on self test.
I said, "I'm writing all these codes for the keyboard, let's just shortcut it."
I originally intended for it to be what we would now call an Easter egg,...
...just something we were using in development, it wouldn't be available elsewhere.
But then the pubs people found out about it,...
...and they're trying to figure out how to tell somebody...
...to start up one of their programs and they had the answer,...
...just put the diskette in, hit ctrl+alt+delete, and by magic your program starts.
So it was like a five-minute job in doing it,...
...I didn't realize that I was gonna create a cultural icon when I did it.
But I have to share the credit.
I may have invented it, but I think Bill made it famous.